we are in a very strange situation I
hope you all take good care keep a
healthy distance and help each other the
economic impact of the Cova 19 outbreak
is severe we need to act fast to manage
the impact as much as we can and we need
to act in a coordinated manner as I
speak we all know about the horrible
situation for people in Italy and the
worsening situation in other member
states also the economy's hard-hit the
sector's first in line our health
hospitality tourism and transport and
many more sectors will face hardship
today we have adopted a temporary
framework it enables member states to
support all kinds of businesses using
the full flexibility foreseen under
stated rules four times as difficult as
these it also enables member states to
act very fast to support businesses in
need
the temporary framework foresees five
different types of support and these
complement already existing options
first they can give direct grants of up
to 800 thousand euros to companies
second they can provide state guarantees
for loans taken by companies from banks
third they can grant loans with
favorable interest rates to companies
fourth the framework provides safeguards
for banks that channel support to
businesses of all sizes
finally member states can provide
short-term export credit insurance if
necessary the yield budget has a limited
size so the main fiscal response comes
from member states national budgets but
also the national budgets will come
under pressure
the temporary framework will help to
target support to the companies and
that's important to avoid negative
consequences for the single market
because we need our
single market to weather this storm and
to bounce back strongly we learned from
the financial crisis how important it is
to act decisively and fast to help our
economy so we drafted consulted with
member states and adopted this new
framework in just a few days we'll
continue to provide all the support we
can to governments and to citizens thank
you